[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم في احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه
من وجدوا والتعهد الرئيس الانتقالي
لبوركينا فاسو ابراهيم تراوري بارسال قوات
الى يمي اذا كان هناك اي تدخل عسكري
الى مدينه كوستا وفي ولايه ريو غرانبيه
البرازيل والمشهد مع سيول وفيضانات واسعه
الى باريس وقرار من اعلى هيئه قضائيه
اداريه يؤيد قرار الحكومه الفرنسيه حضر
ارتداء العباءه في المدارس الفرنسيه
في مواضيع الحصاد
البرهان يؤكد للجزيره عقب محادثاته في
الدوحه حرصه على انهاء القتال والتمرد في
السودان والمضي في استكمال المرحله
الانتقاليه وامير دوله قطر يؤكد حرص
الدوحه على انهاء القتال وانتاج الحوار
روسيا تندد بقرار واشنطن تزويد اكياف
بذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم وتحمل الولايات
المتحده مسؤوليه ما اسمتها التبعات
الماساويه للقرار والفانتاجون يقول ان هذه
الذخائر ستكون فعاله ضد الدبابات الروسيه
تزامنا مع محادثات لسحب عسكريين فرنسيين
الجيش الامريكي يعيل تمركز بعض قوته في
النيجر ويسحب افرادا غير اساسيين
والبينتاكن يقول ان الخطوه احترازيه
مع تصاعد التوتر بينهما ارمينيا تتهم
اذربيجان بالتحضير الاستفزاز عسكري ضد
قواتها ونشر عناصر على طول الحدود
المشتركه اذربيجان تنفي وتصف الاتهامات
بالتلاعب السياسي وتحذر من وضع عقبات امام
اتفاقات السلام
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا دلالات فرض الولايات
المتحده عقوبات على قياديين في الدعم
السريع بالسودان استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم ما هي دلالات اول عقوبات تستهدف
المسؤول الثاني في الدعم السريع والتي
تاتي بعد اتهامات دوليه للدعم بارتكاب
انتهاكات جاءت ردودكم على النحو التالي
58% قالوا ان العقوبات دلاله على تحميل
الدعم السريع مسؤوليه استمرار الصراع
وتدهور الاوضاع
42% اعتبروا ان الخطوه تمثل ضغطا من اجل
العوده للمسار التفاوضي لحل الازمه هذا
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوريا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
على وقع توتر دولي واقليمي اختتام قمه
الاسيان بحضور امريكي روسي صيني
[موسيقى]
قال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الفاني ان مبحثاته مع رئيس مجلس السياده
في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان تهدف
لتعزيز العلاقات وتطوير التعاون بين
البلدين واضاف امير دوله قطر في منشور له
على منصه اكس انه جدد خلال المباحثات حرص
قطر الدائم على دعم الجهود الراميه لانهاء
القتال الدائري في السودان حفاظا على
وحدته وامنه واستقراره
وقد اجرى امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
ال ثاني محادثات في الدوحه مع رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان الذي يزور قطر في جوله كانت شملت
جمهوريتي مصر وجنوب السودان وقال ديوان
الاميريين المباحثات شملت مختلفه تطورات
في السودان وان امير دوله قطر جددت تاكيد
على موقف بلاده الداعي الى وقف القتال في
السودان وانتاج الحوار والطرق السلميه
لتجاوز الخلافات
شيئا فشيئا تتسع الجغرافيا امام رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني وقائد الجيش الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومعها تتسع قدرته على
الفعل والزمان حرب فبعد جولات داخل
السودان وزيارتين لكل من مصر وجنوب
السودان ها هو البرهان في الدوحه
وللوحه سيره من التدخل الحميد في الشان
السوداني منذ ازمه دارفور التي رعت قطر
محادثاتها حتى اثمرت اتفاقيه للسلام لكن
اليوم ليس كامس
فالبرهان يترك وراءه بلدا غارقا في دمه
من جراء حرب نشات مع قوات الدعم السريع
التي يصفها البرهان بالمتمرده وادت الى
سقوط الالاف قتلى والى نزوح ولجوء اكثر من
خمسه ملايين سوداني في الدوحه اكد البرهان
ما قال به من قبل في شان نهايه الحرب
نتمنى انه قريبا
يتم القضاء على هذا السرطان الذي اصاب
الجسم البلد الوطن السوداني وقريبا ان شاء
الله نعمل الشعب السوداني بسلام نحن نفتكر
انه الان نحن نتحدث حديثنا كله عن كيفيه
انهاء هذا القتال كيفيه هزيمه هذا التمرد
وهذا قول لا يدع مجالا لحل متفاوض عليه
قبل حسم المعركه وكان البرهان قد اصدر
قرارا بحل قوات الدعم السريع قبيل مجيئه
الى الدوحه قرار تاخر خمسه اشهر الا
اسبوعا في نظر المطالبين به منذ اندلاع
الحرب كما يطالب هؤلاء بخطوه اخرى تتمثل
في تجريد ضباط وجنود هذه القوات من رتبهم
العسكريه
لتمردهم على الجيش
وقد تواترت الادارات للدعم السريع من
الامم المتحده والمنظمات الحقوقيه وكان
اخرها قرار الولايات المتحده اصدار عقوبات
على اثنين من قاده الدعم السريع بعد
اتهامهما بانتهاكات واسعه بحقوق الانسان
من قتل للمدريين على الشيوع واستهداف
اخرينا لاسباب عرقيه فضلا عن استخدام
العنف الجنسي ضد ضحايا الحرب
والديمقراطيه التي قال حميدتي انه يقاتل
من اجلها ستبدو نافره في سياق حرب تشهد
القتل والانتهاكات ودفع الملايين من
بيوتهم الى مجاهل الارض نزوحا ولجوءا
وشقاء السودانيين بالحرب جعلهم يستبطئون
حسمها وكان الرئيس الكيني وليمبروتو قد
قال في مقابله مع سي ان ان مكالمه جرت
بينه وبين البرهان تراجع فيها البرهان عن
اتهامه لكينيا بالكيد للسودان واكد
استعداده للتعاطي مع الايجاد
برهان لقد اجريت حوارا مع السيد البرهان
الذي سبق واتهم كينيا بالانحياز لبعض
الاطراف لقد تراجع عن اتهامه وابدى جاهزيه
لاستعاده دور منظمه الايجاد في الوساطه
بمساعده دول الجوار كمصر تحرك البرهان في
المنطقه الرماديه كما يشي بذلك حديث
الرئيس روتو ربما جلب عليه نقمه عسكريه
مدنيه ناشئه من موقف لا يرضى بنصف حل في
قضيه تمس جوهر وجود السودان دوله وشعبه
ولزوم منطقه الرماديه تحت شعار لا للحرب
دون اضافه جمله اخرى هي التي انحبس فيها
وفد القوى البدنيه الذي زار يوقندا
واثيوبيا وقطر دون تقديم خطه سياسيه لوقف
الحرب وتاسيس ما بعدها وعلى خلاف المتوقع
جاء البيان السياسي من قوات الدعم السريع
فيما عرف برؤيتها للح
والرؤيه ايا كان شانها مثلت حاله استقلال
بندقيه الدعم السريع عن استلاف الافكار
تلك ازمه القوه المدنيه في الحريه
والتغيير ازمه البرهان انه يبدو لكثيرين
متنازعا بين مطلوبات الطاوله وبين مطلوبات
فكره الحسب النهائي والجمع بينهما يراه
مستعجلوه كتربيع الدائره
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
مجد الانصاري ان موقف بلاده منذ بدء
الازمه السودانيه كان وقف القتال والتمسك
بالحوار واضاف الانصاري للجزيره انه لا حل
عسكريا لنزاع في السودان
المباحثات هذه بلا شك انها ركزت على
الاوضاع في السودان وتطوراتها وخاصه ان
الموقف منذ بدايه هذه الازمه كان واضحا في
الدعوه الى حل هذه الازمه عبر الحوار
وضروره يتم تجنيد المدنيين تبعات القتال
بالاضافه الى ضروره اسباب الامن
والاستقرار في جمهوريه السودان الشقيقه
ولذلك التاكيد من حضره صاحب السموم على
موقف دوله قطر الداعي الى وقت القتال هناك
وانتاج الحوار والسبل السنيه بالاضافه الى
ضروره ان يكون هناك حوار
واضاف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
للجزيره ان هناك حاجه لانهاء القتال في
السودان ثم المرور الى حوار وبحث فرص حل
سياسي مشيرا الى ان دوله قطر تبدي
استعدادها للمساهمه باي شكل ايجابي في هذا
الاطار
طبعا من خلال اتصالاتها في
الجانب الانساني يعني
[موسيقى]
بشكل عام كان هناك قرابه 39 مليون ريال
قطري من المساعدات قدمت من المؤسسات
الاهليه ومن الحكومه الاصليه بالاضافه الى
المشاركه القطريه في مؤتمر المانحين في
يونيو الماضي والذي تعهدت فيه قطر بخمسين
مليون دولار هذا طبعا ناهيك يعني
المساعدات التي كانت على شكل مواد غذائيه
ومواد طبيه وصلت الى اكثر من 371 طنة
من لندن خالد الاعسير الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني سيد خالد ما اهداف جوله
البرهان الخارجيه وصولا الى الدوحه اليوم
تحيه لك ولمشاهدكم الكرام بالتاكيد هذه
الازمه التي عصفت بالسودان بينت مواقف
الدول ووضعت لدى اي مواطن سوداني خطوط
فاصله ما بين التدخلات السافره التي
تستهدف وحده واراده وتماسك الدوله
السودانيه وتلك التي كانت مجرده نزيهه
نقيه في سبيل دعم السودان لتجاوز هذه
المرارات وبالتاكيد من هذه الزوايا انا لا
اريد ان اقول ان البرهان يتجول في صياغه
توزيع الجوائز ترضيه للدول ولكن في سياق
تفاهم تفاهم كبير لقياده الدوله بان بعض
الدول كان لها دور محوري في عمليه ترطيب
الاجواء هو المحاوله بالوصول الى الناس
الى صيغه توافق مرضيه ومن هذه الزاويه انا
في تقدير ان قطر منحت السودان الكثير من
العطاوله وليست ولا تمتن بذلك ولا تحتاج
الى قبول جائزه طردي من الشعب السوداني من
الدوله ولكن هذا امر مستحق ونعلم ان
الكثير من المواقف التاريخيه على سبيل
المثال لدوله قطر وانا لا احكي هنا من باب
مغازله
القطريه وهذا من باب الحقائق قطر لعبه
ادوار مفتاحيه في تاريخ الحياه السياسيه
السودانيه وكلها تصب في مصلحه الانسان
السوداني لم تكن ممتنه لم تكن راغبه في
الحصول على مكاسب راعت اتفاقيات سلام تكاد
تكون هي الانجح وانا متابع لمسيره
الاتفاقيات السلام
موقف امير دوله قطر الدعوه الى وقف القتال
وانتاج الحوار لتجاوز الخلافات كيف يمكن
ان تتفاعل الاطراف خاصه الحكومه السودانيه
مع هذه المطالب بتقديرك
ما كنت اود التكملته ان مسيره الاتفاقات
السلام السودانيه منذ ابوجيا وبشي وسيبيا
في نفاشا انتهيان بالوثيقه الدستوريه وكل
الاتفاقات اللاحقه جميعها كانت فاشله
بامتياز الا اتفاقيتين في عمر الحياه
السياسيه السودانيه منذ عقود مضت كانت
اتفاقيه الدوحه الاولى التي عنيت باتفاق
دارفور وترجمت الى واقع عمل حيث توصلت الى
سلام حقيقي ووصل الموقعون الى تشكيل حكومه
واستمروا في الحكومه الان سقط النظام
السابق وكذلك اتفاقيه الشرق السودان التي
راعتها قطر وايضا تلك التي رعدتها بدعم
خطر كبير اذا من الجيد ان ترعى قطر فكره
ان تكون جزء من عناصر الدفع باتجاه الوصول
الاتفاق سيلان في السودان صحيح ان هناك
منابر اخرى وهذا لا ينفصل يمكن يستمر من
برج جده في تداول القضايا المعنيه وهي
مخصصه بالتحديد للشارع العسكري والانساني
ولا ضرر من ان تكون خطر لديها قوه دفع من
جهه اخرى في اتجاه الوصول الى اتفاق
السياسي بالتاكيد هذا الط الذي تقدم به
والامير تميم اليوم هو يصب في خانه الحاجه
السودانيه وما يطلب الشعب السوداني في
سياق دعم العلاقات
كيف يمكن ان تتفاهم
مع ما طرحه اميداولات خطر خاصه بان السيد
البرهان قال بان المرحله الان بحسب قوله
هي لانهاء ما سماها التمرد
وهزيمته ايضا مر رسائل من السيد البرهان
وكيف يمكن التفاعل مع المطالب التي تدعو
بها الدول ومنها قطر لوقف القتال والذهاب
الى حوار
هو ميزان القوه العسكري البرهان لا يتحدث
من فرق ميزان القوه العسكري صحيحه ان هناك
ضجيج وعزيز لطائرات ودخاخين وقنابل في
سماء الخرطوم ولكن ميزان القوه العسكريه
يتجه باتجاه مصلحه الجيش اذا على القوه
العسكريه المتمرده والتي خرجت عن الدستور
والتي الان اصبحت العدو الرئيس للشعب
السوداني وليس المؤسسه العسكريه فحسب
عليها ان تركن الى صوت الحكمه وتستجيب الى
النداءات الوطنيه لكي تضع سلاح جانبه
تتوقف الحرب حسب حديث البرهان ويتجه الناس
نحو افاق جديده من السلام والاستقرار
التمرد الاراضي يجند الاطفال اصبح يستفيد
من مواقف متناقضه اصبح مطلوب دوليا وهذه
جزئيه مهمه وما يعني مطالبه الاداره
الامريكيه بالعقوبات على عبد الرحيم دقلو
الا عبء جديد على التمرد وخطر تتميز
بعلاقه حميده مع كل الاطراف بلا استثناء
بالرغم من التراكم التاريخي ولكن واضح ان
زياده الحريه والتغيير التي هي كانت جزء
من ادوات تفعيل الصراع في لديها قبول
ولديها مقبوليه وذهبت الى قطر وبالتالي كل
الاطراف تتوافق حول رؤيه وطنيه سياسيه
ولكن هذا يجب ان يتم بعد التوافع على قضيه
اتفاق اعلان جده بالخروج من منازل
المواطنين وتلبيه شروط الاتفاق فيما
الانسانيه لكن فكره تدخل كينيا على سبيل
المثال هذه عمليه فاشله لان كينيا دوله
ليست محايده لديها ارتباطات واستثمارات مع
قوات الدعم السليم وبالتالي هناك دول
عربيه لديها مساحه واسعه في الوجدان
الوطني السوداني يمكن ان تستغل هذه
المنافذ شكرا تحقيق نوعا من الاستقرار
ودعم العمليه السلميه السيد خالد العيسى
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني في لندن
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى موضوع اخر حيث نقل مراسل الجزيره في
البنتاجون عن مسؤول دفاعي امريكي قوله ان
القرار اتخذ بتزويد اوكرانيا بذخيره
اليورانيوم المنظم الان كي تكون جاهزه
للاستخدام مدى تسلمت كياف دبابات ابرامز
وهو امر متوقع في الخريف المقبل لكن
الموعد النهائي لم يحدد بعد وفي موسكو وصف
الكريم القرار بالخبر السيء للغايه وقال
ان استخدام اليورانيوم المنظم سيتسبب في
عواقب وخيمه وحمل الكريم الولايات المتحده
وحدها عواقب استخدام قذائف اليورانيوم
المنضب في معارك اوكرانيا
هل تدخل حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا منعطفا
اكثر خطوره ستحمل هذه الدبابات قذائفه لها
تاثيرات اكثر من اختراق الدروع هذه
الدبابات من طراز ابرز الامريكيه وصلت
دفعات منها للقوات الاوكرانيه خلال الشهور
القليله الماضيه ووعدته واشنطن بالمزيد في
الوقت نفسه اكد الجيش البريطاني تسليم
القوات الاوكرانيه قذائف محمله
باليورانيوم المنظف في مارس الماضي تلك
ماده تنتج في المفاعلات النوويه نتيجه
تخصيب اليورانيوم ولليورانيوم المنظم
استخدامات سلميه كثيره لكن استخداماته
العسكريه اكثر فعاليه من خطوره قد يستخدم
اليورانيوم المنظم في تغطيه الفولاذ
المكون لاجسام الدبابات والطائرات والدروع
ليعطيها حمايه اكثر لكن الجدل يكمن في
استخدام اليورانيوم المنظم في القذائف
عندما ينفجر يمكنه اختراق الدبابات
والدروع بسهوله اكبر اذ تصطدم قذيفه
اليورانيوم المنظم بالهدف لتحترق ذاتيا في
درجه حراره عاليه تنبعث معها جزيئات
اليورانيوم متناهيه في الغلاف الجوي
التاثير الضار يتم عند استنشاق هذه
الجزيئات في رئتي الانسان او ذوبانها في
التربه حذر اطباء الجيش البريطاني من ان
التعرض لليورانيوم المنظم يزيد من خطر
الاصابه بسرطان الرئه واللمفاويه والدماغ
على المدى الطويل تكون الخطوره في تسريب
اليورانيوم المنظم الى مياه الشرب
والسلسله الغذائيه من خلال الهجره من
التربه او الترسيب المباشر على الغطاء
النباتي في المقابل يقول معهد الامم
المتحده لبحوث نزع السلاح انه لا يمكن
اعتباره ذخيره اليورانيوم والمنظم اسلحه
النوويه لانه لا يفي بالتعريف القانونيه
للاسلحه النوويه او الاشعاعيه او السامه
او الكيميائيه لكن تقريرا منذ عام 2010
للجنه العلميه الاوروبيه خلص الى ان هناك
خطرا صحيا محدودا لانفجار اليورانيوم
المنظم موصيه بابعاد مناطق القتال ومعالجه
الجثث المتضرره من هذه الذخائر وجعل
الوصول اليها مستحيل
لكن المناطق التي استخدم فيها اليورانيوم
المنظم لا تزال تعاني الشواهد حيه في
العراق الذي كان مسرحا لهذه القضاء في
الامريكيه في حرب الخليج عام 91 وغزو
البلاد عام 2003 كذلك الامر في صربيا اذ
استخدمه في الحرب هناك عام
رفضا لتهوين الغربي من خطوره هذه القذائف
التي قد تستخدمها كييف تهدد موسكو بان
المنطقه ستدخل منعطفا اخر اكثر خطوره خلال
هذه الحرب وعلى الاجيال القادمه
اذا الينا من موسكو فيكتور
الخبير العسكري والعقيده الاحتياطي في
الجيش الروسي ومن مونتانا مايكل مول روي
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
سيد مايكل ما الهدف الامريكي من تزويد
القوات الاوكرانيه بذخائر اليورانيوم
المنظم يعني ما النتائج المرجوه من هذا
التزويد في حال حصل
ني الانضمام اليكم شكرا على الدعوه اعتقد
انه بصوره اساسيه سنشهد في الاشهر المقبله
دبابه
في الميدان المعركه وهي متميزه
الاوكرانيه من الجهات الغربيه
نحن هادئون لقد اشعلنا النار بهذه
الدبابات التي قالوا انها الافضل في
العالم وسوف ندمر دبابات
ابرهه مع القذائف المنظمه والولايات
المتحده لا تعترف بان
اليورانيوم المنظم يعدي المناطق ويلوثها
وهذا يؤثر على السلسله الغذائيه ويضرر
بالشعب ولكن الايطاليين الذين حاربوا فيه
غسلافيا
وتم
نشر العدوى في بينهم بهذه الاشاعات هم
يحصلون على مساعدات حكوميه لانهم مرضوا
بامراض سرطانيه
واستخدام هذه القذائف الامريكيه التي
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم سوف تدمر
الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وتلغيها من قائمه الاراضي
الحيه لانها سوف تصبح اراضي ومواقع تقتل
الشعب حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب لذلك النتيجه
الولايات المتحده تقوم باعمال اباده
جماعيه ضد الشعب الاوكراني من جانب هم
يحاربوا روسيا
بالمقاتلين الاوكرانيين والشعب الاوكراني
ومن طرف اخر سوف يدمر هذا الشعب باستخدام
هذه القذائف التي تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم سيد مايكل انت قلت بان للونانيوم
المنظم اشاعات محدوده اذا كان هذا صحيحا
المشكله ليست بالاشاعات بحد ذاتها وانما
روسيا والكرملين يقول بان هذا سيدخل
المنطقه منعطفا اخر اكثر خطوره على
الاجيال القادمه الا تخاطر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بادخال هذا السلاح لارض
المعركه في اوكرانيا بمواجهه روسيا
الجيش الروسي هو الذي يبيد الشعب
الاوكراني جماعيا اوكرانيا طلبت هذه
الذخيره وهي تدرك المخاطر التي تترافق
معها وهي تريد ان تدافع عن اراضيها ضد
جارتها التي اجتاحتها واذا فتشنا في
الدراسات اضافتش المشاهدون عن
الدراسات حول الموضوع هي طبعا فيها خطر
ولكن ليس بالقدر الذي تحدث فيه الزميل نحن
نستخدمها في ميدان التدريب في الولايات
المتحده دعونا اذا نفكر بهذا الموضوع حين
نسمع هذه المبالغات اذا ذخائر باليورانيوم
المنظم لا تغيروا اللعبه هي طبعا مؤثره
اكثر
وبعد اكثر مع طائرات الاف 16 المقاتله
التي تعطي اوكرانيا
بعضا من التقدم بالنسبه الى تفوق العسكري
الجوي اذا يمكن اطلاقها من
منصات التي تمتلكها
اوكرانيا
ويمكن ان توضع في شبكات اللوجستيه التي
تحتاجها الجيوش لتدعم نفسها يمكن ان تصل
الى شبه جزيره القرم
اذا المكاسب التي راينا اوكرانيا تحققها
في اخر ايام
لاسيما بالجنوب الى مناطق اخرى يمكن ان
تتعزز حين تصلها الاسلحه الاخرى في ميدان
المعركه سنرى ذلك المشاهدون سيرون ذلك
بدون ان يسمع وصفا لا سيرونها بام العين
اذا فعلا استمرت هذه الحمله وسوف نرى
المزيد من المكاسب تحققها اوكرانيا
كيف نفهم التهديد الروسي في رد روسيا على
احتماليه تزويد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ذخائر يورانيوم منظب للقوات
الاوكرانيه
انا قلت مسبقا عن الرد اولا سوف
نقوم بالمناقشه هذه المساله في مجلس الامن
وفي الامم المتحده والعالم كله يعتبرون ان
هذه القذائف التي تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظف هي سموم تسمم الاراضي والتربه وهذا
حدث في غسلافيا عندما استخدمت الولايات
المتحده مثل هذه القذائف وبالطبع سوف نقوم
بتدمير
واضح ساعيد صياغه السؤال بطريقه اخرى
هل سيغير هذا المعطى الجديد من استراتيجيه
روسيا في تعاطيها مع ميدان الحرب في في
اوكرانيا هذا هذا هو السؤال
كلا لن يتغير اي شيء ولا بحال من الاحوال
لان اوكرانيا هي تحت الاداره الامريكيه
وتحت مدربين
الناتو المتخصصين وهي تخسر يوما بعد يوم
اما كونها تحصل على بعض النجاحات فهذه
خرافه يقوم تقوم الاداره الامريكيه بنشرها
ولكن حاليا ليس هناك اي هدف معلن من الطرف
الامريكي
والاوكراني لم يتم النجاح فيه ولن
يستطيعوا القيام بذلك هل سوف يستخدم
القذائف التي تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
ام لا بغض النظر عن هذا سوف تهدم اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده والناتو حتى الاف 16 لن
تساعدهم في اي نجاحات لانها طيارات قديمه
ولا تستطيع القيام باي شيء ضد
الطيارات الروسيه
اخوي 30.35 لذلك شكرا لا اقول هنا ان في
اوكرانيا ليس هناك طيارين من الممكن ان
يستخدموا هذه الطيارات وقيادتها
واستخدامها في المعارك
ولن يستطيعوا ان يتدربوا عليها قريبا ليس
هناك متخصصين من الممكن ان يخدموا هذه
الطيارات في المطارات العسكريه وليس هناك
مطارات عسكريه من الممكن ان تخدم هذه
الطيارات او متخصصين ممكن ان يقوموا على
خدمتها لذلك هذه الاعلانات الامريكيه
والرغبات انهم يعلنون عن رغباتهم وكانها
واقع وهذا ليس كذلك وهذا شكرا السبب بهذه
اوكرانيا في موسكو السيد فيكتور ليفوكين
وفي مونتانا السيد مايكل
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البانتاجون
اعاده تموضع بعض قوات الجيش الامريكي في
النيجر وذكر البانتاجون ان الولايات
المتحده ستسحب عددا من الافراد غير
الاساسيين من باب الحذر الشديد بحسب
تعبيره وتعتبر هذه الخطوه اولا تحرك
عسكريين امريكيين في النيجر منذ انقلاب
يوليو تموز ويوجد بالنيجر ما يقدر بالف
ومئه جندي امريكي
تواصل قوات الامن فرض
فرض طوق امني في محيط السفاره الفرنسيه في
نياميه وتمنع الدخول والخروج من مقر
البعثه الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه دون تفتيش في
تطورات ايضا قالت حركته ان 62 التي ترفض
وجود القوات الفرنسيه في النيجر لا ستبدا
اليوم برنامجا للتظاهر والاحتجاج يستمر
لمده اربعه ايام يشمل تنظيم اعتصام ليوم
واحد امام القاعده العسكريه والاحتشاد في
استاد العاصمه هذا ويعقد الاتحاد العام
للنقابات الحره في النيجر اجتماعا لاعلان
موقفه بشان التطورات في البلاد ومن رحيل
القوات الفرنسيه
والسفير الفرنسي
في هذه الاثناء نفى مفوض المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس عبد
الفتاح موسى خوض المجموعه في نقاشات بشان
اي نوع من عمليات الانتقال السياسي مع
قاده الانقلاب في النيجر واكد ان المجموعه
الاقلبيه مستمره في مطالبها بالافراج
الفوري عن الرئيس محمد باسوم واستعاده
النظام الدستوري واشار الى ان مجموعه
ايكواس لم تحدد تاريخا للتدخل العسكري
وانها تمنح الفرصه لعمليات الوساطه
والعقوبات لدفع المجلس العسكري الى طاوله
المفاوضات
الدكتور لورانس فريمان الخبير المختص في
الشؤون الافريقيه دكتور كيف تفهم
قرار عفوا قرار اعاده نشر القوات
الامريكيه في النيجر
الولايات المتحده تقريبا
1100 الى 1200 جندي في النيجر
واعتقد انه لدينا ست قواعد بالاضافه الى
قاعده كبيره للمسيرات لم تطلب حكومه
النيجر من الولايات المتحده ان تغادر ولكن
القوات الفرنسيه ما يقارب 1500 منها طلب
منها ان تغادر كذلك سفير الفرنسي الولايات
المتحده في موقف صعب لانها ارادت ان تدعم
النيجر وان تنطلق منها من اجل مكافحه
الارهاب في الساحل ولكن فشلت
ولكن الرئيس بايدن وزير الخارجيه
بلانكن اذا لم يتحدث عن انقلاب لانه هو لم
يريد قطع العلاقه وبالتالي الولايات
المتحده لا تتحرك بطريقه مكثفه لان الوضع
خطير ولكن صوره عامه لقد خسرت اللعبه انصح
القول خسرت ثقه شعب النيجر وخسرت الولايات
المتحده قدراتها على اعتبار ان يجارك
قاعده عسكريه من اجل المراقبه والمتابعه
في الساحل دكتور مع التعثر المسار السياسي
في النيجر هل
اعاده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نشر بعض
قواتها في النيجر اي مؤشر على المرحله
المقبله
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده قلقه جدا
واعتقد انها ترغب في ان تعود الحكومه
السابقه هي دعامات منظمه الايكواس وطبعا
ايكوس كانت تدعو لتدخل عسكري بمجرد ان حصل
ان انقلاب ولكن قد لا تتمكن من ذلك
هذا تمرد ضد الاستعمار الفرنسي وتمرد ضد
اي تدخل عسكري خارجي لانه لا فرنسا ولا
الولاه المتحده قد ساعدت الشعب النيجر
الذي يعتبر من الافقر في العالم 3% من
السكان فقط لديهم قدره الوصول للكهرباء
اذا هذا ثمن غباء سياسه سياسات الغربيه ان
لم نرفع مستوى معيشه الشعب سوف يتمرد سوف
يثور والشعب في النيجر ثار ضد فرنسا اذا
الولايات المتحده تخسر في افريقيا في غرب
افريقيا وفي اجزاء اخرى من افريقيا ايضا
هذا الى ان تغير من سياستها الفاشله يجب
ان تعتمد سياسات تنمويه انا ادعو اليها
لكن الحكومه لا تصغي لي شكرا لك الدكتور
لورانس
[موسيقى]
الموضوع اخر حيث قال رئيس الوزراء
الارميني نيكولب باشنيان ان اذربيجان حشدت
قوتها على طول خط التماس مع كاراباخ
والحدود مع ارمينيا ودعا بشنيان المجتمع
الدولي الى اتخاذ اجراءات لمنع وقوع ما
سماه انفجارا جديدا في المنطقه وشدد رئيس
الوزراء الارميني على ان بلاده مستعده
لابرام اتفاق سلام وتطبيع العلاقات مع
اذربيجان
قواتها على طول الحدود المشتركه بينها
وبين ارمينيا وبالقرب من منطقه ناجورنو
كارباخ انفصاليه اصبحت التصريحات المناهضه
للارمن وخطاب الكراهيه اكثر حده في
الصحافه الاذربيجانيه وعلى المنصات
المستعمله للدعايه
وكانت مواقع اخباريه اذربيجانيه نشرت صورا
قالت انها لقوافل عسكريه اذربيجانيه متجهه
الى الحدود مع ارمينيا تاتي هذا التحركات
بالتزامن مع علانيه ريفان عن تدريبات
عسكريه امريكيه ارمينيه مشتركه تنطلق في
الحادي عشر من الشهر الجاري وتستمر حتى
العشرين منه وتشهد المناطق الحدوديه بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا اشتباكات متجدده يتبادل
فيها الطرفان الاتهامات حول خرق اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار
بينما كويريفان عميقه وقديمه سياسيه
وعرقيه وجغرافيه عنوانها اقليم كندا قبيلا
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي اندلعت حرب بين
البلدين الجارتين المنضاويتين تحت العلم
الاحمر كان الهدف من الهجوم الارميني
السيطره على اقليم كندا تتغلل ارمينيا
بالاغلبيه الارمينيه في الاقليم سته اعوام
من القتال خلفت الاف القتلى ونزوحا من
الطرفين
الحرب التي انتهت عام 94 انتهت بسيطره
ارمينيا مدعومه من روسيا على 20% من مساحه
اذربيجان توقف اطلاق النار حينها على هذه
الخريطه لكن النار لم تهدا بين الطرفين
بعد 16 عاما شنت اذربيجان هجوما واسعا على
المنطقه بعد سته اسابيع من القتال وقع
الطرفان اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق النار في موسكو
استعادت باكو مدعومه من تركيا السيطره على
المناطق التي خسرتها خسرت ارمينيا الحرب
وتجرعت مراره الهزيمه
بقيت في الاقليم مناطق تخضع لما يعرف
بجمهوريه ارتساخ غير المعترف بها دوليا
والمدعومه من ارمينيا اعطى الاتفاق
لارمينيا ممرا الى المناطق الانفصاليه
تحفظ السلام فيه قوات روسيه
في المقابل حصلت اذربيجان على طريق يصلها
باراضيها ما وراء الحدود الارمينيه
قالت باكو ان الارمينيين لم يلتزموا بفتح
الطريق فاغلق الاذربيجانيون
دلع القتال وتوقف باعلان روسي بعد مقتل
عشرات الجنود
التوتر بين الجارين يلفت انظار العالم
تتهم واشنطن موسكو بالسعي الى اذكاء
التوتر لتعزيز نفوذها في المنطقه تراقب
اوروبا وتحذر من تدهور الاوضاع وعينها على
الغاز الاذربيجاني ينظر الى خط انابيب
الغاز هذا على انه احد شرايين الغاز
المهمه لاوروبا في مواجهه انقطاع الغاز
الروسي المحتمل يحث الجميع الطرفين على
البحث عن حلول على الطاوله
[موسيقى]
ربما الدكتوره تمارا درجاتزي الاكاديميه
والباحثه المختصه في شؤون القوقاز دكتوره
ما العوامل التي تحول دون خفض التصعيد على
حدود الدولتين
انه المستمر لان الاتفاق كان قد تم توصل
اليه على ان اذربيجان سوف تفتح ممر لاتشين
وهو الذي يمتد من ارمينيا
[موسيقى]
في الاراضي الاذربيجانيه ولكن
بما انا اقدر قالت انها قلقه من تهريب
السلاح الى كهرباء من ارمينيا عبر هذا
الممر قالت انها بحاجه الى تفتيش كل سياره
كل مركبه تمر
اما ارمينيا فترى ان ذلك سوف يمنعها من
الحصول على المواد الغذائيه والامدادات
الطبيه من اجل عيش الشعب وهذا امر غير
مقبول بحسب ما تقوله ارمينيا اضافه الى
ذلك يقولون ان روسيا يجب ان يكون لديها
قوات حفظ السلام من اجل ضمان المساواه
والسلام وهذا لا يحصل
لان
البضائع لا يمكنها المرور بهذا الممر الى
ارمينيا هذا ما تقوله ارمينيا اما
اذربيجان فهي تصر على ضروره التفتيش عن
اسلحه في كل ما يمر وانه اذا كان بحاجه
الى امدادات غذائيه وطبيه وغيره يمكنهم ان
يحصلوا عليها
اخر انت ذكرتي روسيا ما الانعكاسات
المحتمله لعدم قدره روسيا الضامن في
المنطقه هكذا تصف نفسها روسيا من
الانعكاسات لعدم قدرتها على خفض التصعيد
بين الدولتين والانعكاسات محتمله على
المنطقه بشكل عام
هذا ما تقوله ارمينيا هذا ليس
على ما يرام وانه بكل بساطه يجب ان نسيطر
على ما يمر عبر هذا الممر وارمينيا يجب ان
تقبل بممر بديل
لتمر عبر هو البضائع الاساسيه طبعا
روسيا تقف على الحياد ربما لا تريد ان
تفرض رايها على اذربيجان وتحاول ان تساعد
ارمينال انها حليفتها وهي معها في الاتحاد
الجمركي ولكن ربما هذا وضع ليست روسيا
مستعده للتدخل فيه اذا ارمينيا تشعر
بالخيانه شكرا لك يا دكتوره تمارا درجاتزي
في لندن
[موسيقى]
تعرض قناه الجزيره مساء غدا الجمعه تحقيقا
جديدا ضمن برنامجها ما خفي اعظم حيث يفتح
ملف استهداف المحتوى العربي على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي ووفق التحقيق الذي يحمل
عنوان الفضاء المغلق عبر تسريبات ومقابلات
حصريه اليتستهداف المحتوى العربي وخصوصا
الفلسطيني وتقييد وحظر الاف الحسابات
والمفردات العربيه بطريقه مثيره للجدل
وقام فريق برنامج ما خفي اعظم الذي يقدمه
تامر المسحال ببحث وتجارب مستقله على مدار
اشهر لاختبار اليات الحظر والتقييد خصوصا
على منصه فيسبوك والتي نالت الجزء الاكبر
من الاتهامات والانتقادات باستهداف
المحتوى العربي والفلسطيني وتمكن البرنامج
من مقابله شخصيات مسؤوله عده على صله
بالملف من بينهم مسؤولون سابقون في فيسبوك
وحقوقيون كما التقى مقدم البرنامج احد
اعضاء المجلس الاشراف في فيسبوك للرد على
نتائج التحقيق
تحقيق ما خفي اعظم الفضاء المغلق ياتيكم
مساء غد الجمعه عند العاشره وخمسه دقائق
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه على شاشه الجزيره
ومنصاتها المختلفه كونوا على الموعد
[موسيقى]
اكد المجلس الوزاري لدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي على ان ملكيه الثروات الطبيعيه في
المنطقه المغموره المحاذيه للمنطقه
المقسومه السعوديه الكويتيه بما فيها حقل
الدره بكامله هي ملكيه مشتركه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ودوله الكويت فقط ولهما
وحدهما كامل الحقوق في استغلال الثروات
بتلك المنطقه واكد المجلس الوزاري الخليجي
على رفض القاطع لاي ادعاءات بوجود حقوق
لاي طرف اخر في هذا الحقل او المنطقه
المغموره المحاذيه للمنطقه المقسومه
بحدودها المعينه بين البلدين
يشهد مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين
قرب مدينه صيدا اشتباكا بالاسلحه الرشاشه
بين عدد من المسلحين في منطقتي الطوارئ
والبروكسات داخل المخيم يذكر ان هيئه
العمل الفلسطيني المشترك في لبنان كانت قد
كلفت قبل يومين بل كلفت القوى الامنيه
التي تضم كافه الفصائل والقوى الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه والاسلاميه في المخيم بالعمل
على تنفيذ المهام الموكله اليها وذلك بعد
انقضاء المهله التي كانت قد حددت لتسليم
المشتبه بهم في عمليه اغتيال قائد قوات
الامن الوطني الفلسطيني في صيدا ابو اشرف
العرموشي ورفاقه نهايه شهر حزيران يونيو
الماضي
قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لمراقبته
ومكافحه معاداه الساميه انه يدين تصريحات
الرئيس محمود عباس التي وصفها بالبغيضه
والمعاديه للساميه وحثه على تقديم اعتذار
فوري اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فقط قال ان
خطاب الرئيس محمود عباس به تصريحات وصفها
بالكاذبه والمضلله بشكل صارخ بشان اليهود
ومعاداه الساميه وردا على هذه التعليقات
عبر الناطق باسم رئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيله
ابو ردينا عن استهجان الرئاسه وادانتها
لما وصفه بالحمله المسعوره لمجرد اقتباسات
لكتابه اكاديميه وتاريخيه واوضح ان موقف
الرئيس محمود عباس من هذا الموضوع واضح
وموثق وهو الادانه الكامله المحرقه
النازيه ورفط معاداه الساميه وكان الرئيس
محمود عباس قد قال امام المجلس الثوري
الحادي عشر لحركه فتح في اواخر اغسطس ان
ادولف هتلر امر بالقتل الجماعي لليهود
بسبب دورهم الاجتماعي
كمقرضين للمال وليس بسبب عدائه لليهوديه
اختتمت اليوم في العاصمه الاندونيسيه
سلسله قمم لرابطه دول جنوب شرق اسيا امتدت
على مدى خمسه ايام وانتهت بقمه شرق اسيا
الموسعه بحضور عشرين دوله وتعهدت الدول
المشاركه بتعزيز السلامه والاستقرار في
البحار وحريه الملاحه والتحليق في اجوائها
وممارسه ضبط النفس
سلسله قمم اسيان تختتم بقمه موسعه لشرق
اسيا بحضور دول كلولات المتحده وروسيا
والصين وعلى وقع توتر اقليمي تفادى البيان
الختامي ذكرى حاله دوله بعينها مع التزام
الدول المجتمعه بامن وسلم البحار المشتركه
بينها وضبط النفس وعدم استخدام القوه ضد
الدول الاخرى
نحن المجتمعين في هذه القمه نتحمل مسؤوليه
الحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار والازدهار
في المنطقه كما نتحمل مسؤوليه عدم خلق
صراعات او نقاط توتر جديده ونحن مسؤولون
عن تخفيف اي توتر وتهيئه اجواء للحوار
وتجد رابطه اسيان اليوم لمنظومتها
الاقليميه افقا استراتيجيا جديدا ذا
امتداد جغرافي اوسع انها منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ وتريد اسيان ان تجعله
محورا للتن لا ساحه صراع وفي قمه بلادها
مع دول اسيان اكدت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
التزام بلادها بالحضور الامني والدفاعي في
المنطقه وقد شهد هذا العام مناورات عسكريه
للولايات المتحده وحلفائها في المياه
الاسيويه وهي اخذه بالتوسع ضمن تكتلات
تترسخ معالمها
وتاتي قمم اسيان على وقع توتر في بحري
جنوب وشرق الصين فقبل ايام اصدرت الصين
خارطه اقليميه قبلت برفض من بعض دول اسيان
جاكرتا دعت الى ضروره بناء الثقه بين دول
اسيان والصين بينما حذرت بيجين من
التكتلات الجديده والتدخلات الخارجيه نمت
الخلافات والنزاعات قد تحدث بين الدول
بسبب سوء الفهم والتباين في المصالح او
بسبب التدخلات الخارجيه مهما كان السبب من
الضروري مواجهه تلك القضايا بوضوح لازاله
اي سوء فهم فمواجهه المشاكل هي مطلب اساسي
قبل حلها
تواجه دول اسيان موقفا منه التحديات
والفرص في ان واحد فهي تتوسط المسافه بين
دول المحيطين الهند والهادئ حيث يحتدم
التدافع ولهذا تسعى الى الحفاظ على
مكانتها واستقرارها بينما تحيط بها نقاط
ساخنه يخشى اشتعالها صهيب جاسم الجزيره
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه لحصاد الليله نقترب اكثر
من اعلان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي البدء في
تحويل ثلاث بؤر استيطانيه في الضفه
الغربيه الى مستوطنات قائمه بذاتها
ومحاوله شرعنتها خلافا للقانون الدولي
يتعلق الامر ببؤره افيجايل الاستيطانيه
العشوائيه المقاومه على تلال جنوب الخليل
وقد قرر الاحتلال توسيع مساحتها الى نحو
ثلاثه اضعاف من 75 دونما استولى عليها
المستوطنون الى اكثر من 200 دونم اما
البؤره الثانيه فتسمى عشهال او اساهيل وهي
ايضا تقع على تلال جنوب الخليل وقد تقرر
توسيعها 18 مره عما كانت عليه اي من 55
دونما لتصبح نحو 900 دونم بينما تقع
الثالثه وتسمى بيت حجله في منطقه
باريحا على ضفاف البحر الميت وهي اراض
فلسطينيه مستولى عليها عام 2001 وستكون
تلك البؤره الاستيانيه اولى البؤر التسع
التي اقرت حكومه نتنياهو في فبراير الماضي
شرعنتها مثل جعفات ارنون وملاخي هشالوم
على اراضي قريه المغير شرق رام الله اضافه
الى بؤره ماتسبيه هدى المقاومه على اراضي
جنوب شرق القدس والمزمع توسيعها ايضا لتضم
2011 سكنيه للمستوطنين كما يخطط الاحتلال
لتوسيع بؤره سيدي بوعز في بيت لحم الى
2000 دونوميت ويكتمل بذلك الحزام
الاستيطاني جنوب وغرب بيت لحم ليكون كتله
استيطانيه ضخمه على حساب اراضي الفلسطينيه
المد الاستيطاني في الفتره الاخيره تكشف
عن ضخامته ارقام واحصائيات بعضها لجهات
اسرائيليه كحركتي السلام الان وكرم نبوت
فمنذ مطلع العام الجاري اعلنت الحكومه
الحاليه مخططات لاقامه 12,000 وثمانمائه
وحده استيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه ووقت
حركه السلامه الان وجود
146 بؤره استيطانيه ومستوطنه في الضفه تضم
نحو نصف مليون مستوطن اضافه الى
200 الف مستوطن في اربع عشره مستوطنه في
القدس الشرقيه وبحسب التقرير السنوي لهيئه
مقاومه الجدار والاستيطان يبلغ عدد
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه بما فيها
شرقي الضفه الغربيه وشرقي القدس نحو
726500 مستوطن موزعين على مئه وس ته
وسبعين مستوطنه ومئه وسته وثمانين بؤره
السلطانيه لنفهم المشهد اكثر ينضم الينا
من القدس السيد خليل التفكجي الخبير في
شؤون الاستيطان سيد خليل ما ابرز ملفتك في
هذا المشروع الاستيطاني التوسع الجديد
لقوات الاحتلال
هو تطبيق لصفقه القرن التي وضعت في عائلته
وضعت في الفتره السابقه ورفضها
الفلسطينيون وقد جاءت هذه الصفقه عباره عن
مجموعه مشاريع اسرائيليه بتوقيع امريكي
وبالتالي عندما تنظر الى عمليه التوسعات
والبؤره الاستيطانيه التي قامت او التي
ستقام في داخل الضفه الغربيه تلحظ انها في
منطقه الاغوار وبالتالي منطقه الاغوار
بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي يعتبرها جزء من
الحزام الامني الاسرائيلي الذي يفصله عن
الجبهه الشرقيه وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه من
الضفه الغربيه التي هي تشرف على منطقه
ديمونه وديمونه كما هو معروف في منطقه
الفرن الذري الموجود في تلك المنطقه يضاف
الى هذا وذلك تطبيق
للقرارات الاسرائيليه السابقه التي صدرت
في 79 عندما طرح متتياه دروب الاسرائيلي
الوكاله الصهي ونيه انا ذاك عن مليون
مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه ومشروع الاوامر
العسكريه التي صدرت في 83 وهو قضيه
الطرق او الامر العسكري رقم 50 للطرق في
سنه 83
ما الهدف الاسرائيلي سيد خليل ممكن ان
نبسطه اكثر بالنسبه للمشاهد من هذه
المشاريع الجديده
بكلمه بسيطه جدا عدم اقامه دوله الفلسطيني
لذا التواصل جغرافي هذا هو النتيجه
السيطره على الارض ترسيم الحدود بين وجهه
نظر اسرائيليه تقطيع اوصال الضفه الغربيه
من شرقها الى غربها بالشوارع العريضه كما
هو سيحدث في منطقه جنوب نابلس ايضا وضع
مليون مستوطن يشكلون دوله ذات سياده في
داخل الضفه الغربيه هي تمنع اقامه اي دوله
فلسطينيه في المستقبل طيب يعني واضح بان
هذا يتم رغم الدعوات الدوليه لوقف
الاستيطان كيف ترى المواقف الغربيه
والدوليه في هذا السياق
انا بتذكر عندما كان ونائب رئيس اوباما
ومنع وتم تجميد وحدات سكنيه في داخل ملك
القدس وبالضفه الغربيه وعندما
جاء بايدن وانتشرت وبدات اعمال البناء
الاستيطاني انا لا انظر الى الاستنكارات
والادانات وغير ذلك انظر الى ما يحدث على
الارض عمليا كان هنالك في عمليه السلام
110.000 في عام 1993 اليوم في ايار او
مايو سنه 2023
بلغ عدد المستوطنين في داخل الضفه الغربيه
60 وفي القدس عنا 230 الف اذا سنصل الى
المليون مستوطن في السنوات القادمه طبعا
السؤال الذي يطرح الان من اين سياتون
هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
اسرائيليه من الداخل الى داخل الضفه
الغربيه هل يكتفي الاحتلال سيد خليل هل
يكتفي بهذه المشاريع ما المخطط الطويل
الامد اذا صح التعبير الاحتلال
في عنا مشروع عام 2050 طبعا اقامه مطارات
اقامه سكك حديديه حتى المشروع بشكل عام
سنه 2050 وبالتالي هذه الرؤيه الاسرائيليه
الواضحه تماما مليون مستوطن بالاضافه
لزيادتهم اقامه اكبر مطار في منطقه اريحا
وهي في منطقه النبي موسى حوالي يستقبل 35
مليون مسافر 12 مليون سائح سكك حديديه في
وسط الضفه الغربيه تربط المنطقه الساحليه
مع منطقه الاغوار مع منطقه الشرق الاوسط
الاردن وغير ذلك حتى تصل الى العراق طبعا
انتهت في سكه حديديه انتهت اللي هي تبدا
منها منطقه حيفا حتى غور الاردن في الشمال
وطبعا استكمالها شوارع عرضيه تبدا من
مدينه القدس حتى الجسم الملك عبد الله
المغلق حاليا باتجاه الاردن ثم اذا الرؤيه
الاسرائيليه هي منطقه شرق اوسط الشرق
الاوسط جديد تحت سقوطنا الاسرائيليه
في شؤون الاستيطان في القدس
[موسيقى]
العالم والطقس ضرب الاعصار هايكوي جنوب
شرقي الصين مع حجم امطار تخطى الارقام
القياسيه المسجله منذ 12 عاما العاصفه
دانيال تجتاح اليونان منذ الاثنين الماضي
قتلى ومفقودون وانهيارات ارضيه وتدمير طرق
واعمده كهرباء وجرف عشرات السيارات وفي
تركيا تسببت امطار غزيره في سيول وفيضانات
ادت الى سقوط قتله كما تسببت الامطار
الغزيره في عدد غير مسبوق من الفيضانات في
انحاء جنوب شرق اوروبا مما اسفر عن تدمير
للبنيه التحتيه وصدور اوامر بالاجلاء يقول
مرصد كوبرينكوست للمناخ التابع للاتحاد
الاوروبي الادله العلميه دامغه سنواصل
مشاهده المزيد من الارقام القياسيه
المناخيه وظواهر الطقس المتطرفه بشكل اكثر
حده وتكرارا مما سيؤثر على المجتمع
والانظمه البيئيه لحين توقفنا عن اطلاق
الضاره نسال السلامه للجميع ختام الحصاد
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]